'facebook de nuevo en el punto de mira
de la justicia esta vez han sido las
fiscalías de 48 estados y la autoridad
reguladora del comercio en eeuu la que
ha demandado a la compañía de mark
zuckerberg la acusan de infringir la
legislación en pro de la libre
competencia al haber mantenido
ilegalmente su monopolio del sector
particularmente con la compra de
eventuales rivales como instagram y
whatsapp
hoy actuamos y nos ponemos del lado de
millones de usuarios y pequeños negocios
que han sido perjudicados por la
conducta ilegal de facebook así que
pedimos a la corte que detenga e impida
a la compañía seguir haciéndolo en el
futuro perder candado
restableciendo la competencia del
mercado nuestra demanda ayudará a los
consumidores a tener alternativas a
facebook
la reacción de la empresa ubicada en
california ha sido rápida advierte al
gobierno federal del impacto sin
precedentes que esta iniciativa
supondría no sólo para las empresas sino
para los usuarios de la red facebook se
hizo con instagram en 2012 por mil
millones de dólares mientras que en 2014
absorbió whatsapp por un valor de 19 mil
millones de dólares ahora ante lo que
consideran como conductas
anticompetitivas
las opciones del usuario los demandantes
piden que el tribunal obligué a facebook
a reestructurar su negocio obligándolo a
vender instagram y whatsapp google fue
también demandado en octubre por el
departamento de justicia y amazon y
apple han sido sometidas a
investigaciones federales también por
conductas anticompetitivas